hoping to echo those words from 20 years
ago of winning a fourth division title
in five years this time around an a.l
west crown as we get ready for baseball
on this wednesday night with a magic
number of one luis garcia takes the hill
tonight for the astros
young right-handers had a great season
29 games 27 of them have been starts a
beautiful 3.23 era you see that bottom
line he has been very good at home
there's a strikeout on three pitches
luis garcia
makes quick work of brandon lau to start
this game
and here's wanda franco switzer betting
left is garcia wind up delivers swing at
a ground ball fair down the third base
line into foul ground and
coming a long way to chase it as jordan
alvarez throws to second and wonders got
a first pitch double and the rays get
their first hit of the night and he also
extends his on bay streak right away to
a record-tying 43 consecutive games ties
frank robinson who did it for cincinnati
back in the 56 season
with the longest
on bay street 43 he's going to go to
third as that ball bounds away from
maldonado
and the rays have a runner at third
with one out
swing and a miss big strikeout for luis
garcia getting nelson cruz for out
number two
got him
got him with the cutter down and in
underneath the swing of window luis
garcia strikes out three in the first
taking the mound tonight for the tampa
bay rays their starting pitchers are
presented by bake here it's going to be
right-hander drew rasmussen look what he
has done in his last seven starts
basically since he moved into the
rotation for good the record great 2-0
but look at the era and the whip just
not giving up any base runners attacking
the strike zone
fastball sky to right field
phillips there to make the catch
three fly ball outs one to left one to
center one to right no score through one
swing and a miss luis garcia who hasn't
had four strikeouts in a start in the
month of
september since the fifth has four
strikeouts now in his first four
outs there's a high fly ball back into
right field
with some carry that ball is going to be
off the glove of siri
phillips continues to run
and he's going to wind up at third
[Applause]
phillips gave it a ride
siri and tucker both converging and they
could not siri could not corral that one
he overran it i mean he overran it he
gets there he goes too far now it's
behind him phillips
at third two outs in the second
ground ball that's through into right
field of base hit and the rays will take
the lead brett phillips crosses the
plate
and it's one-nothing tampa bay
nice job by mejia to get that through
the right side
wild swings gets under this one that
baby's gonna fly gone
home run to ride by brandon loud
a two-run shot it's three-nothing tampa
bay
home run number 35
a two-run shot
alvarez big time power
and he is out on strikes
breaking in on him
he gets ready for october baseball
tonight was a pretty important outing he
gets g-man troy to bounce one to guriel
gets the force there the return throw
for the double play julie de carlos back
to yuli
that could be a gold glove tandem if all
goes well in the offseason
there you go
that's wendell for the second time
tonight that's now five strikeouts for
luis garcia we head to the bottom of the
third in the three-nothing game and it's
different and it's loud and it can be
you know it can jar you if you're not
used to it so you want a calm cool
collected guy out there and there's
another one two three inning three in a
row for
rasmussen we go to the fourth three
nothing braves
winning games every which way runner on
the go the throw by maldonado a good one
out at second base is kier meyer martin
maldonado with his 17th caught stealing
of the year maldonado cuts down another
runner this ball popped up muldee doing
maldives yes he did
martine maldonado getting out from
behind the plate
what a play by maldi just got done
throwing out kier meyer and now he's
laying out for luis to in this inning
incredible play ray's after there 98th
win
this one lifted toward left center and
that ball is caught out there by margot
manuel margot a diving catch into left
center field and you saw the expression
from rasmussen margaux goes horizontal
then we'll see what g-man choi can do
he swings and sends a fly ball into deep
right center and out of here
home run
joy on the first pitch
launches one a three-run blast and the
rays will take a six-nothing lead
and if you're putting pitchers in good
spots you can get a lot of early outs
and that's what we've seen from here
it's been pretty
pretty awesome
302 popped into short center
keermeyer makes the catch face hit the
man left we're through five six nothing
raised
so five innings of one hit
shut out baseball for drew rasmussen and
now patino
never
born crown ball left side dwindled up
with it this throws in plenty of time
but he's hit the man left
we go to the seventh six nothing raise
tapper to third
windows throws in time
three up three down
onto the eighth six nothing raise
brett phillips oh for three tonight
and he sends this one into right center
field that's gonna be extra bases
scoring wendell
phillips
on his way for three and he's gonna make
it now he's gonna come home and the
throw is gonna be in time
well he had a triple for sure
and tried to circle the bases and was
out by plenty
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
up there after it made the catch
all right franco spring-loaded
to respond to that line drive off the
bat of diaz
3-2
and he got him a cut and a miss on that
3-2 pitch to end this one and the rays
are winners 7-0